[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen ich bin Toni Heyer und
ich bin Mirko Kasimir wir begrüßen euch
zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Tatort
Deutschland und heute haben wir eine
wirklich ungewöhnliche Geschichte auf
jeden normalerweise geht es ja dann doch
ziemlich blutig zu heute haben wir aber
mal keine Story in der es um Mord oder
Totschlag geht das ist das eine noch
ungewöhnlicher ist dass die Hauptfigur
unserer Geschichte vor Gericht unbedingt
beweisen wollte nein sogar musste dass
sie ein Verbrecher ist und der Cast der
Story der hat auch in sich unter anderem
treten auf Jan Vermeer das ist einer der
berühmtesten Maler aller Zeiten also das
Bild von ihm das Mädchen mit den
Perlenohrring das hat jeder bestimmt
schon mal gesehen
unter anderem mit dabei Jesus beim
Abendessen Hermann Göring und Hand von
mehreren und mit dem fangen wir am
besten an denn das ist der Mann der vor
Gericht verzweifelt seine Schuld
beteuerte
[Musik]
henricos Antonius van mecheren genannt
Hang wird im Herbst 1889 in davinton
geboren einer kleinen Stadt in den
Niederlanden ungefähr auf halbem Weg
zwischen Münster und Amsterdam schon als
Kind bewundert er die Werke der alten
holländischen Meister eines Tages möchte
er selbst ein Künstler sein und als
junger holländischer Meister Geld und
Ruhm ernten ja Künstler das wollen viele
werden und die meisten Eltern schlagen
dann die Hände über dem Kopf zusammen
wenn Sohn oder Tochter sowas sagt mach
was vernünftiges heißt das dann meine
Mutter hat immer gesagt junge lass das
brotlose Kunst naja wir sehen wo wir
heute stehen und genauso ist es auch
hier denn Hans Vater drängt ihn zu einem
Architekturstudium und Hang lässt sich
widerwillig darauf ein Architektur das
muss für ihn so ziemlich das schlimmste
gewesen sein also wenn man da ja
technische Zeichnungen anfertigen muss
mit Lineal und gespitzten Bleistift
super penibel und sauber alles das ist
ungefähr so als wenn man jemanden der
Ballettänzer werden will ihn dann dazu
zwingt den Stechschritt einzuüben dieses
Bild ist wirklich schrecklich
dazu studierte er noch ausgerechnet in
Delft der Geburtsstadt eines seiner ganz
großen Helden Jan Vermeer der wurde 1632
in Delft geboren blieb zu seinen
Lebzeiten jedoch relativ unbekannt ist
heute aber einer der berühmtesten
niederländischen Maler während seine
Studiums lernt funmakerin die
Kunststudenten Anna de Vogt kennen die
beiden heiraten im April 1912 und noch
im selben Jahr wird ihr Sohn Jack
geboren
ein Jahr später bricht Hahn sein
Architekturstudium ab um stattdessen an
einer Kunstschule in den Haar zu
studieren er macht sein Diplom und
beginnt zu unterrichten er arbeitet als
Assistent eines Professors für
Kunstgeschichte und verkauft eigene
Zeichnungen unter anderem als
Weihnachtskarten und Poster
1915 kommt ein zweites Kind zur Welt
Pauline und 1917 eröffnet hanfan
mehreren in den hach eine erste
Ausstellung seiner Werke und hat
riesigen Erfolg
daraufhin wird er in eine sehr exklusive
niederländische Gesellschaft von Malern
und Schriftstellern aufgenommen der
harte künstig aber das Glück bekommt
bald Risse
1923 lassen sich Anna und er scheiden
die Gründe dafür sind seine Untreue und
seine Trinkerei und damit ist Hahn
solo
den konntest du dir nicht verkneifen ne
ja entschuldigung da bin ich nicht
drumrum gekommen und eigentlich ist es
auch gar nicht wichtig aber nun solo bzw
Single ist als Maler ist er jedenfalls
ziemlich erfolgreich naja zumindest was
das Finanzielle angeht er malt Portraits
und volkstümliche Bilder mit Titeln wie
junger Hirsch oder Straßensänger und sie
verkaufen sich super sein Stil
orientiert sich dabei sehr an dem von
ihnen so verehrten alten Meistern das
gefällt dem Publikum die Kritiker und
die Kollegen die hassen es für Sie
produziert von mehreren nichts anderes
als puren
kitscherin überwirft sich mit der Szene
er betrachtet sich als verkanntes Genie
und in ihm reift ein Plan
wenn man seine Gemälde im Stil der alten
Meister als Kitsch verteufelt dann wird
er Ihnen eben seine Gemälde als
verschollene Werke der alten Meister
selbst unterjubeln Herr wollen wir doch
mal sehen ob sie immer noch
kitschkriegen wenn sie glauben es mit
einem echten Gemälde aus der ganz großen
Zeit der niederländischen Malerei zu tun
haben mit einem echten vermehrt
Stil hat er schon lange studiert jetzt
perfektioniert er seine Technik
er mischt seine eigenen Farben und
verwendet ausschließlich Zutaten die zu
vermehrtszeiten üblich waren er fertigt
in Handarbeit Pinsel aus dachsan wie
vermehr sie verwendete ein großes
Problem ist dass Ölgemälde sehr sehr
langsam trocknen dadurch ist es noch
lange möglich festzustellen ob ein Bild
wirklich im 17 Jahrhundert gemalt wurde
oder vielleicht erst vor 20 30 Jahren
solange willhaben von melcherin
natürlich nicht warten er entwickelt
nach vielen vielen Experimenten eine
eigene Technik bei der er den Farben
Spuren von Bakelit beimischt und sie
dann in einem Pizzaofen backt ein echter
Pizza vermehrt das gefällt mir
was vermehr für Hanse interessant macht
ist das von ihm nur wenige Gemälde
bekannt sind gerade einmal 37 Stück von
Rembrandt sind zum Beispiel noch etwa
350 erhalten und so glauben viele dass
es noch viel mehr vermehrt vermehrte
vermehre was ist der richtige Plural ach
egal also Bilder von Vermeer geben muss
die vielleicht einfach noch nicht
entdeckt sind wirklich genial ist aber
noch ein anderer Gedanke ran von
Michelin beschließt ein Werk zu schaffen
dass ich von allen anderen vermehrt
unterscheidet ein Werk das angeblich aus
einer früheren Schaffensperiode des
Malers stammt aus der keine Bilder
überliefert sind das ist wirklich super
clever von ihm würde er ein Werk im Stil
von vermehrt sozusagen Greatest Hits
helfen also im Stil von z.B Mädchen mit
dem Perlenohrring oder dienstmarkt mit
Milchkrug
dann würde jeder kleine Fehler jede
kleinste Abweichung von vermehrt Stil
sofort auffallen wenn die Leute aber
glauben dass es ein Werk aus einer
anderen bisher unbekannten Phase
vermehrt ist dann könnte man jede
Abweichung ja genau damit begründen
sich sehr kluger Schachzug
und Hang überlisten nichts dem Zufall er
studiert die Bücher eines der
berühmtesten familienexperten dr Abraham
bradius der hat die Theorie aufgestellt
dass vermehr früher religiöse Gemälde
gemalt haben müsse bevor er seinen
eigenen Stil und seine eigenen
alltäglichen Themen fand und haben der
alte Fuchs der malten Bild mit dem Titel
Christus und jünger in Emmaus das genau
darauf abzielt die Theorie von bradius
zu untermauern es sieht ein bisschen wie
ein vermehrt aus aber doch ganz anders
also wie ein Bild von vermehrt der sein
Stil einfach noch nicht gefunden hat und
dann sorgte dafür dass es genau diesem
Doktor bradius zur Begutachtung
vorgelegt wird und dr bradius ist
begeistert in einem Artikel jubelt er
wir haben hier so bin ich geneigt zu
sagen das Meisterwerk von Johannes
vermehrt aus Delft ganz anders als alle
seine anderen melde und doch ganz und
gar ein vermehr Hut abhand von mehreren
guter Schwindler Fälscher oder
Hochstapler der muss ja aber nicht nur
die Technik beherrschen sondern vor
allem ein verdammt guter Psychologe sein
von mehreren lieferte predius genau das
was der brauchte um sich aufzuplustern
und auf die Brust zu trommeln und zu
rufen seht ihr habe ich doch schon immer
gesagt huldig dem schlauen dr bredius
also das ganze Zeit halt komplett auf
sein Ego ein er hat ziemlich gut erkannt
dass Wunschdenken ganz schön den
Verstand vernebeln kann ich sage nur
ganz anders als alle seine anderen
Gemälde und doch ganz und gar ein
vermehrt
ja das ist ein bisschen wie als würde
ich sagen guck mal wie runter das ist
ganz eindeutig ein Viereck
[Gelächter]
es gibt ein paar Experten die Zweifel an
der Echtheit haben oder sogar offen von
einer Fälschung sprechen aber bradius
Expertise überstrahlt alles das größte
Kunstmuseum Rotterdams kauft 1937
Christus und die Jünger in Emmaus für
550.000 Gulden das entspricht ungefähr 4
Millionen Euro heute mit seinen eigenen
Bildern also dem Kitsch ist von mehreren
zu einigem Wohlstand gekommen mit den
Fälschungen aber da wird er richtig
richtig reich oh und natürlich wagt es
niemand den angeblichen vermehrt als
Kitsch zu bezeichnen und weil das so gut
lief fälscht kann von Michelin munter
weiter und bleibt dabei seiner Methode
treu Bilder zu malen die ganz anders
aussehen als alle anderen vermehrt
mit bradius im Rücken fällt es umso
leichter die neuen Fälschungen als echt
anerkennen zu lassen und für viel Geld
zu verkaufen und einer seiner Kunden
wird Hermann Göring
1942 sind die Niederlande von
Deutschland besetzt über den
Kunsthändler Alois miedel verkaufte er
den fake-vermehr Jesus und die
Ehebrecherin an den Reichsmarschall
Kunstliebhaber und Kriegsverbrecher
der kauft überall in dem besetzten
Gebieten wertvolle Kunstwerke auf und
noch mehr raubt er bzw lässt er rauben
für Jesus und die Ehebrecherin bezahlt
der 1,65 Millionen Gulden das Geld dafür
stammt aus dem Verkauf von mehr als 100
von den Nazis geraubten Kunstwerken auf
seinem Land sitzt Karin Hall in der
Schorfheide in Brandenburg hortet Göring
unermessliche Kunstschätze Jesus und die
Ehebrecherin ist ein Juwel seiner
zusammen gestohlenen Sammlung und eins
seiner persönlichen Lieblingsstücke als
im Frühjahr 1945 die Rote Armee auf
Berlin vorrückt lässt er einen Großteil
der Werke darunter den falschen Familie
nach Bayern schaffen dort werden die
Werke aber von amerikanischen Soldaten
konfisziertürigen selbst wird am 7 mai
1945 festgenommen und in Nürnberg als
Kriegsverbrecher zum Tode verurteilt im
Oktober 1946 nimmt er sich das Leben
Hand von mehr dagegen ist gut durch den
Zweiten Weltkrieg gekommen äußerst gut
seine Fälschungen haben ihn irre reich
gemacht allein in Amsterdam besitzt er
mehr als 50 Immobilien dazu kommen 15
Landhäuser er lebt auf großem Fuß und
lässt es richtig krachen während Europa
in Schutt und Asche versinkt und normale
Amsterdamer einen schlimmen
hunger-winter durchleiden am 5 mai 1945
endet die deutsche Besatzung der
Niederlande und kurz darauf steht die
Polizei Vorhang von Michaels Tür aber
nicht um ein Fälscher festzunehmen
sondern einen Verräter ihm wird die
berühmt berüchtigte deutsche Bürokratie
zum Verhängnis Görings Diebstähle und
Käufe sind genauestens dokumentiert auch
der Kauf eines Gemäldes mit dem Titel
Jesus und die Ehebrecherin der Handel
kann schnell zu Hahn von Michelin
zurückverfolgt werden und er wird
verhaftet ja weil er ein unschätzbares
nationales niederländisches Kulturgut an
die Nazis verkauft hat das wird als
feindbegünstigung und schwerer Verrat
angesehen hanfern mehreren droht die
Todesstrafe und so kommt es dass Hahn
von michlerin vor Gericht mit allen
Mitteln versucht zu beweisen dass er ein
Verbrecher ist ein Kunstfälscher und
kein Verräter ja er habe das Gemälde an
den Kunsthändler Alois miedel verkauft
und der habe es Angehörigen
weiterverkauft aber das Bild sei mit
nichten ein echter vermehrt es sei viel
mehr ein echter von mechernen und er
habe nicht etwa niederländisches
Kulturgut an die Nazis verscherbelt
sondern einen der schlimmsten Nazis
hereingelegt der Prozess wird natürlich
zur Sensation
es ist gar nicht so leicht das Gericht
von seiner Schuld zu überzeugen experten
sagen gegen ihn aus und beharren auf der
Echtheit des Gemäldes er muss in
Untersuchungshaft vor Zeugen eine
weitere Fälschung anfertigen um seine
Behauptung zu beweisen als die Anklage
wegen verrats- und Feind Begünstigung
schließlich fallen gelassen wird steht
Hand von mehreren in den Augen der
meisten Niederländer als Held da ein
Schlitzohr einer von ihnen der erst die
hochnäsigen kunstfahrzeuges an der Nase
herumgeführt und danach einen der meist
gehassten Nazis über den Tisch gezogen
hat und diese Geschichte macht die 1947
laut einer Umfrage zu einem der
beliebtesten noch lebende Niederländer
also auch wenn ich die Story herrlich
amüsant finde wir müssen sie gleich aber
ein bisschen entzaubern aber vorher
erzählen wir sie noch zu Ende Jan von
Michelin wird am 12 november 1947 wegen
Fälschung und Betrug zu diesem Jahr
Gefängnis verurteilt aber Toni einem
Typen wie Hahn fährt auch bestimmt
irgendwas ein um dem Knast zu entgehen
oder ja klar nur leider ist die Sache
nicht so lustig oder amüsant wie
erwartet einen Tag bevor seine
Einspruchsfrist gegen die Haftstrafe
endet und er dann in den Knast gemusst
hätte da leidet Hand von mehreren einen
Herzanfall er kommt in eine Klinik
stirbt dann aber kurz darauf am 30
dezember an einem erneuten Herzanfall
man kann also sagen um den Knast ist
herumgekommen und starb dann in Freiheit
und als Held
[Musik]
ja was für eine Geschichte aber wie
gesagt müssen wir diese Suppe noch ein
ganz klein bisschen versalzen hanfern
Michelin war nicht der große Held als
den in viele sahen ja vielleicht wollten
sie ihn einfach unbedingt so sehen
vielleicht hat die Geschichte vom
gewitzten Niederländer der einen
Obernazi aufs Kreuz liegt der volkseele
einfach verdammt gut nach all den Jahren
der Besatzung nach den Deportation
jüdischer Mitbürger die in den
Niederlanden besonders gründlich waren
nach Anne Frank und der Zerstörung von
Rotterdam durch Görings Luftwaffe nach
dem Hunger Winter aber das mindeste was
man in Bezug auf Hand von Michelin
festhalten muss ist dass er mit
Sicherheit kein Widerstandskämpfer war
er profitierte vom Krieg und an der
Besatzung so wurde ihm beispielsweise
einer seiner vermeintlichen families von
niederländischen Patrioten abgekauft um
sie im Ausland vor den Nazis in
Sicherheit zu bringen und mehrere seiner
Amsterdamer Immobilien stammten von
Juden die von den Nazis in die
Vernichtungslager deportiert wurden und
es gibt außerdem Hinweise darauf dass
Harn von mechernen selbst ein Nazi war
und zwar so richtig ein glühender Hitler
Verehrer in Hitlers Bibliothek in der
Reichskanzlei fand man ein Buch mit
Zeichnungen von Hahn von mechernen
komplett mit einer Widmung
meinem geliebten Führer in dankbarer
Anerkennung h Punkt von Michelin hier
schließt sich der Kreis da versucht sich
der falsche später selbst als Opfer
einer Fälschung darzustellen zwar sei
die Unterschrift tatsächlich von ihm er
habe ja so viele Exemplare des Buches
signiert aber der Rest des Textes den
müsste jemand gefälscht haben in diesem
Punkt sind die Experten bis heute bei
ihrer Meinung geblieben die Widmung ist
echt ja aber und damit kommen wir zum
letzten Twist in dieser Story die große
und bis heute ungebrochene Popularität
von mehrerens führte dazu dass
schließlich tatsächlich Werke von ihm
gefällt und dann für hohe Summen
verkauft wurden also Fake von mehrerens
Mirko ich muss gestehen ich finde das
ist ein wirklich
sehr kreativer Mittelfinger an diese
ganzen Kritiker von ihm die ihn ja
eigentlich durch diese abfällige Kitsch
Bemerkung so richtig auf den Trichter
gebracht haben das ist richtig aber
natürlich die ganzen politischen
Hintergründe und sein Handeln und sein
partizipieren von der damaligen
Situation das sollte man natürlich nicht
vergessen und spielt in meinem Kopf auch
eine sehr wichtige Rolle was die
Anerkennung seiner Leistung betrifft ja
auf jeden Fall dass das ganze macht die
Story ein bisschen madig aber ich glaube
das wäre auch eine Diskussion für sich
ist ja ähnlich wie richtig muss man
Künstler und Musik zum Beispiel trennen
da gibt's ja auch ganz viel Diskussionen
aber das ist nichts was wir heute lösen
müssen und damit sind wir am Ende
unserer Geschichte angelangt vielen Dank
fürs Zuhören die Geschichte eines der
genialsten und berühmtesten
kunstfälschers aller Zeiten haben wir
unter anderem erzählt anhand des Buches
die data Detective von Tim harford von
Artikeln auf nPA dort die collector.com
und financial times.com danke fürs
zuhören und hoffentlich bis bald bei
Tatort Deutschland eure Toni und eure
Mirko